[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 c'est l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale en 26 minutes tout de
suite les titres de ce jeudi 7 février
ils concentrent des espaces de recherche
et de formation des ateliers des
laboratoires tous tournés vers de
nouveaux modes de déplacement le mobile
a été inauguré ce matin par différents
partenaires dont le département des
yvelines un site implanté au coeur du
cluster de versailles satory face à la
crise des gilets jaunes c'était l'une
des mesures annoncées en décembre par
emmanuel macron attribuer une prime
exceptionnelle aux salariés éligibles
les chefs d'entreprise ont eu le choix
de verser ou non ce dispositif
exemple dans cette édition au sein d'une
pme et d'une clinique privée du
département et cet ancien fort militaire
protégeant pan de la culture française
le centre national du cinéma est à bois
d'arcy
il abrite les archives du film un lieu
qui nous a exceptionnellement ouvert ses
portes c'est la découverte patrimoine de
la semaine des invités également dans ce
journal pascal rodier du secours
populaire d asie vie dont on parlera
également du temps des femmes qui se
déroule à guyancourt avec sa mère marie
à christine le tarnec et cathy blandeau
responsable du service action culturelle
mais avant carlos ghosn aurait-il
profité pour son bénéfice personnel d'un
contrat de mécénat entre renault et le
château de versailles le groupe
automobile s'interrogent sur le
financement du mariage de son ex pdg
célébré en octobre 2016 sur le site
yvelinois estimant qu'il pourrait s'agir
d'un abus de bien social le château de
versailles aurait enregistré pour les
festivités
l allocation du grand trianon comme
contrepartie d'un contrat de mécénat a
signé avec renault en juin 2016 une
prestation de 50000 euros pour un
événement privé et sans aucun lien
direct pourtant avec ce mécénat
renault envisage de signaler ces faits
au parquet son ancien patron et pour
rappel incarcéré depuis novembre au
japon notamment pour abus de confiance
et de son côté le château de versailles
précise dans un communiqué que renault
comme le prévoit la loi sur le mécénat a
le droit à des contreparties à hauteur
de 25 % ni à carlos ghosn est ni à son
mariage ne sont cités dans ce communiqué
versailles satory paul des nouvelles
mobilités ce matin était inaugurée
le mobile à d'un espace de recherche des
ateliers et des laboratoires didier il
associe l'institut vd comme l'opérateur
transdev et l'institut de recherche iw
star mélanie poquet étaient sur place
plus de 7000 m² entièrement dédié à la
mobilité un bâtiment hybride de
recherche de conception située à
versailles-satory le mobile à ben est un
projet pensé il ya trois ans l'idée
c'est vraiment de constituer ici et la
mort d'un cluster ca kloster c'est à
dire un lieu où se marient la créativité
les idées d'acteurs différents
on sait bien qu'aujourd'hui l'innovation
elle a besoin justement de sortir du
cloisonnement trois acteurs sont
installés dans les locaux depuis
l'automne dernier les instituts vd comme
l'ip star et l'opérateur transdev on est
vraiment tous ensemble sur des projets
communs et surtout avec la totalité des
moyens à disposition de la recherche des
plus académiques jusqu à
l'expérimentation
ce qui est très bien aussi c'est qu'on a
un
des pistes d'essai du zèle et l'autre
côté qui nous permettent de faire les
premiers tests des nouvelles
technologies avant de les déployer
nous travaillons aussi sur la la
convergence des sciences pour
l'ingénieur et des sciences humaines et
sociales
parce qu'il ne suffit pas d'avoir des
objets qui sont extraordinairement bien
conçu s'ils ne sont pas réellement
utilisés en toute sécurité
ce projet mais l'acteur public et privé
d'un coût d'environ 18 millions d'euros
le site a bénéficié de l'aide du
département et de l'agglomération
versailles grand parc
c'est dans ce département que
l'essentiel de la production mais aussi
de la conception automobile française se
fait pour nous c'est évident qu'il
fallait participer pour une
intercommunalité 1 millions 6,7 ou même
sommes significatives
il fallait participer à ce grand projet
aujourd'hui 200 personnes travaillent
sur le site les premières recherches
concernent notamment les véhicules
électriques et leurs recharges se
chiffre à présent dix mille c'est le
nombre de médecins libéraux qui seront
en âge de partir à la retraite dans cinq
ans en ile de france cela représente 50
% des effectifs actuels et des médecins
qu'il est de plus en plus difficile à
remplacer selon le dernier rapport de
l'agencé régionale de santé sur l'année
2018 une région qui n'est pas épargné
par la désertification médicale
l'île de france est passé en quelques
années de privilégier et richement dotée
à un territoire avec le plus grand
nombre d'habitants faisant face à des
difficultés d'accès aux soins
le sénat s'est prononcé prononcés à une
large majorité la chambre a rejeté par
246 voix contre 78 la privatisation
d'aéroports de paris le groupe à la
gestion dans les yvelines des aérodromes
de toussus le noble sens irait chavenay
villepreux cette privatisation est
prévue par la loi pacte qui autoriserait
l'état à vendre une partie ou la
totalité de ses actifs dans l'entreprise
soit un peu plus de 50% des parts qui
représente 9,5 milliards d'euros
c'est l'assemblée nationale qui aura le
dernier mot sur le texte adopté en
première lecture les chefs d'entreprise
avaient le choix attribue au nom une
prime exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat
défiscaliser aux salarié es
et bhl l'une des mesures annoncées par
le président de la république pour
répondre à la crise des gilets jaunes
dans les yvelines certaines sociétés se
sont saisis de ce dispositif c'est le
cas à coignières et à port marly
reportage d'aurélie rose et de nicolas
landry c'est un des produits phares de
la pm automation 2000 le dg pt 2 un
dispositif d'alerté de sécurité pour les
transformateurs électriques dans cette
entreprise 10 salariés ont bénéficié
d'une prime de 1000 euros fin décembre
2018 le seuil maximal de la mesure
annoncée par le président de la
république fin décembre ça nous a bien
aidés tout à fait je suis tout seul
c'est très dur paix loyer manger
heureusement que je travaille ici quand
même il cette prime ça ne veut pas ça
nous permet par exemple d'y aller en
vacances ces employés sont éligibles car
gagnant moins de 3600 euros par mois au
total la société a versé 10 mille euros
au lieu de quatorze mille euros grâce à
la défiscalisation que j'estime que les
salariés le mérite de toute façon je
pense que c'est important le pouvoir
d'achat c'est un sujet qui travaillent
tout le monde au quotidien et les
entreprises aussi petite soit elle
doivent essayer de participer à l'effort
même situation à la clinique de l'europe
de port marly un établissement privé de
260 lits il emploie 400 salariés 75 % du
personnel a bénéficié d'une prime de 200
euros soit 377 employés on l'a eu
rapidement souvent on voit d'abord le
versement sur le compte qui arrive donc
on voit que c'était pas prévu travail et
un week-end sur deux de 8h à 20h vous
avez une vie de famille et vie sociale
pour 1300 euros 1400 euros pour moi je
pense que la prime ça fait plaisir mais
c'est tendu
il nous a semblé important de donner une
infinie reconnaissance à nos salariés
qui a dépassé l'année auprès des
passions ils font tous un métier
difficile
cette disposition est prévue par la loi
du 24 décembre 2018 les entreprises ont
jusqu'au 31 mars 2010 9 pour utiliser
cette réforme
[Musique]
il savait forcément en ce moment c'est
le grand débat national des élus des
communes des citoyens et même des
associations ont décidé de s'associer à
ce temps de consultation c'est le cas du
secours populaire français bonsoir
pascal rodier bonsoir vous êtes le
secrétaire général du secours populaire
des yvelines alors l'association remet
en place ces cahiers le dire pour agir
pour recueillir la parole de ses
bénéficiaires aussi des bénévoles sur le
terrain le secours populaire c'est un
participant légitime indispensable à ce
grand débat je pense que les autorités
apprécieront moi je ne sais pas si on
est légitime pour donner la parole aux
plus démunis je pense que oui depuis la
fin des années 80 c'est un dispositif
qu'on connaît bien
le grand débat national il s'agit pas de
prendre parti plus que ça j'ai devant un
relais
voilà et la difficulté on le voit dans
les informations c'est la prise de
parole des plus éloignés de la décision
politique c'est celle ci de parole qui
est difficile à recueillir les modalités
en elle-même du débat ne facilite pas le
recours à internet
il ya quand même 7 millions de français
cap à internet donc pour participer à un
débat sur internet c'est compliqué pour
ces personnes là et il se trouve que
souvent c'est lé public qu'on reçoit
dans les permanences d'accueil vous
évoquez justement les années 80 puisque
l'action pour le secours populaire en
tout cas n'est pas nouvelle en 88
l'association avait déjà mis en place
des cahiers de doléances pour recueillir
cette parole en fait on s'était préparé
au bicentenaire de la révolution à
l'époque et on s'était dit que c'était
ce serait pas mal de rééditer des
cahiers de doléances et donc à l'époque
les bénévoles du secours populaire avait
sillonné un petit peu les cages
d'escaliers un petit peu tous les lieux
de vie pour recueillir la parole des
personnes est justement celle à qui on
la donne pas souvent la parole et c'est
à cette époque là qu'on avait ressorti
la donne et fait ressortir la la grande
précarité qui se développait et qui
émergeait déjà dans notre
territoire et c'est à l'issue de cette
dynamique là qui a eu le progrès le
premier programme européen d'aidé aux
démunis
j'ai eu des progrès grâce à cette action
qui a été mis en place dès les années 80
contexte de précarité qui existe
toujours aujourd'hui qui est toujours
difficile en en france l'an passé sur ce
plateau
vous étiez venu nous parler de
l'augmentation du nombre de
bénéficiaires dans les yvelines plus de
7000 en 2017 est ce que c'est un chiffre
qui a augmenté l'année dernière en 2018
oui puisqu'on a dépassé on est quasiment
aux 9000 et on est pas une
une fédération énorme en termes
d'activité donc j'ai pas les chiffres
nationaux en tête mais c'est vrai que on
a de plus en plus de gens qui poussent
la porte du secours populaire et dans
tout ce qu'on a entendu depuis deux mois
sur ce que les les retraités témoignant
que c'était de plus en plus difficile de
joindre les deux bouts et tout ça mais
ça fait plus de dix ans qu'on dit qu'il
ya des seniors qui reviennent dans les
permanences d'accueil est en fait c'est
pour ça que cette participation grand
débat national
elle va être assez facile il va suffire
qu'on ressorte tous nos rapports
d'activité depuis une dizaine d'années
puis il y aura les éléments de dans quoi
et pour témoigner danser etc et ils sont
déjà en place dans la fédération ils
vont être réédités en fait c'est une
réédition
on a reçu la version pour les enfants
copains du monde puisqu'on est aussi une
association qui tient à faire participer
les enfants dès le plus jeune âge à la
solidarité dont il ya une édition
spéciale on va dire pour les enfants les
enfants qu'ils puissent en fait exploser
leur quotidien ce dont ils manquent ce
dont il rêve ce dont ils ont envie et ça
va être réédité et ça va être diffusée
on l'espère de manière un peu structuré
aussi sur la durée
parce que ça permet aussi de d'associer
les personnes qui sont aidées à toutes
les solidarités qu'on peut mettre en
place derrière et donc c'est un outil on
le fait beaucoup à l'oral puisque ça
fonctionne beaucoup à l'oral dans les
permanences d'accueil
on essaye de ne pas être trop
administratif aussi avec les gens
puisque c'est une manière plus souple de
lier des liens des clés les personnes et
donc il ya énormément énormément de
témoignages sous qui sont souvent oraux
des bénévoles et des bénéficiaires est
beaucoup d'eau et on va essayer de
recueillir c'est un petit peu plus
systématiquement quoi le secours
populaire qui s'associer à ce grand
débat autres sujets dont je voulais
parler avec vous cet appel lancé aux
familles de vacances des familles pour
accueillir des enfants qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de partir en vacances
un enfant sur trois ne part pas en
vacances en france ce constat est le
même dans les yvelines il ya beaucoup
d'enfants qui ne qui ne peuvent pas
partir en vacances
oui on n'échappe pas alors souvent dans
le grand public on est on pense que les
yvelines c'est un gars est un
département riche si on le haut si on
fait la moyenne
rapporté à la population mais c'est
aussi justement un département un des
départements où il ya le plus d'écart
entre les plus riches et les plus
pauvres
puisqu'il ya des gens qui sont très
riches filles et des personnes qui sont
très pauvres sur un territoire commun
chanteloup les lignes par exemple sur
11000 habitants où je vais avoir 40 % de
la population qui vit en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté donc on peut pas dire
que ce soit des personnes lésées malgré
le fait qu'elles vivent dans un
département riche donc
donc voilà c'est c'est pour ça aussi que
dans notre département on a toujours un
besoin de familles de vacances bénévoles
qui se proposent pour prendre un copain
des vacances on appelle ça un enfant
pendant 15 jours ou trois semaines pour
lui faire partager sa vie quotidienne
ses loisirs ses vacances puis faire
peut-être découvrir un peu de nouveaux
horizons et dans l'autre sens ça permet
aussi à des personnes qui connaissent
pas forcément les questions précarité
qu'ils peuvent rencontrer une partie de
nos concitoyens de toucher un petit peu
du doigt ça et puis d'avoir des échanges
qui parfois dure dure presque une vie on
peut dire il ya de ryad et il ya des
aspects comme ça on sait que ça dure
pendant plusieurs années et que les
liens se maintiennent un droit
fondamental pour les enfants de partir
en vacances ça permet de s'évader de ce
quotidien qui peut être difficile
pas complètement et puis bah c'est pas
nouveau non plus depuis les congés payés
on a bien constaté ce que ça pouvait
apporter comme bien-être y compris aux
classes laborieuses c'est quand même a
priori celles qui ont le plus besoin de
vacances celles qui travaillent et donc
les gens qui sont privés d'emploi il n'y
a pas forcément de raison non plus
qu'ils soient privés de vacances de
loisir de découvrir d'autres choses de
s'oxygéner la tête et puis préparer un
séjour de vacances c'est aussi se
projeter dans le temps et parfois ça
rend service aussi à des personnes qui
ont des difficultés pour la gestion de
leur quotidien se projeter dans le temps
ça les aide après pour gérer un petit
peu leur budget et préparer les vacances
de son enfant
c'est aussi pour un parent qui sait que
son enfant va partir dans une famille de
vacances c'est aussi pour elle
l'occasion de revaloriser aussi un petit
peu sa fonction quoi c'est à dire bah je
peux quand même offrir un bon enfant des
vacances même si moi j'y vais pas mon
enfant peut partir en vacances quoi
l'appel est donc lancé si vous souhaitez
accueillir l'un de ses enfants pour des
vacances se retrouver toutes les
informations sur le site du secours
populaire merci pascal rodier êtes par
l'association ce plateau secrétaire
général du secours populaire des
yvelines
[Musique]
à plaisir dans un an le parc des quatre
saisons aura un nouveau visage pensé par
la ville et les habitants un chantier de
plus de sept cent mille euros qui
devrait débuter en 2020 les précisions
de mélanie poké 4 hectares de verdure au
coeur de la ville le parc des quatre
saisons situé dans le quartier de
l'aqueduc de lavera plaisir va être
réaménagé on a une partie qui va être
beaucoup plus familial une partie qui va
être beaucoup plus espace vert familial
pour faire des pique niques pour y
manger mais il y aura aussi des jeux
d'enfants qu'il y à déjà mais qui vont
être améliorés il y aura toute une zone
aussi qu'il sera une zone plus culturel
puisqu'on va mettre en place un théâtre
de verdure il y aura des représentations
pourquoi pas de poésie ou de théâtre
et puis il y aura aussi des aménagements
qui sont des aménagements plus sportif
avec des tables de ping pong avec la
possibilité de faire du hand a
légalement un réaménagement voulu par la
ville et penser avec les habitants en
octobre et novembre dernier deux
réunions de concertation ont été
organisées ce mardi le bilan était
présenté aux plaisirs oit ils n'ont pas
remplacé autant les amusements sinon le
reste l'aménagement le fait d'avoir des
arbres pour le soleil pour l'ombre cet
été on en avait besoin
tout ça c'est vraiment bien fait c'est
un
un parc où j'ai beaucoup emmener mes
enfants quand ils étaient plus jeunes
j'ai envie qu'ils grandissent et qu'ils
puissent continuer à avoir de l'activité
à ce qu'on puisse venir le week-end en
famille en profite et 70 habitants ont
participé à l'élaboration de ce nouveau
parc
le projet coûtera 7 144 mille euros le
démarrage des travaux est prévu pour le
mois de février 2020 c'est organisé
depuis huit ans à guyancourt le temps
des femmes peau cette année une question
l'égalité où en est-on pour en parler
d'eux invités autour de cette table
marie-christine le tarnec bonsoir ça dit
la maire divers gauche de guyancourt
également khatib landau bonsoir
responsable du service action culturelle
à guyancourt alors le gros du programme
sera en mars mais ce temps des femmes a
déjà démarré avec l'exposition soyons
affiché qui se déroule en ce moment à la
salle d'exposition c'est jusqu'au 24 24
mars on va en parler dans un instant en
huit ans que la ville organise ce temps
des femmes marie christine le tarnec
c'est une question de l'égalité femmes
hommes qui est qui est importante pour
la ville alors nous c'est au quotidien
effectivement qu'on essaie de réduire
les inégalités
alors que ça soit au niveau du service
effectivement des municipalités au
niveau des habitants au niveau de la de
la ville par exemple on féminise toutes
nos fiches de poste parce que je pense
qu'il ya pas de métier réservé aux
femmes comme il ya pas de métier réservé
aux femmes aux hommes on a dix-sept
postes de direction dont 10 femmes et
les chefs de service et effectivement si
sont sont pour la majorité des femmes
donc on travaille sur cette parité
et puis en direction des habitants eh
bien on a différentes actions il y a le
service jeunesse et qui montre des
actions de prévention en pour les jeunes
sur
sur l'inégalité sur les discriminations
enfin sur différents thèmes qui qui
peuvent effectivement les intéressés et
puis le service culturel par exemple eh
bien on veille à ce que la programmation
de notre salle de culture elle est bien
respecte la parité on accueille aussi
bien des auteurs des artistes femmes que
des artistes masculin et puis cette
année on a une originalité par danse
dans notre programmation puisque le
thème ces deux matrimoine l'école des
parents à des à une action aussi quitte
un peu original en direction des pères
pour leur permettre de se d'avoir une
réflexion autour de leur place
effectivement la famille pourquoi pas
rééquilibré aussi les rôles au sein au
sein du ménage
et puis on a effectivement à une chose
aussi qui est très importante c'est
favoriser aussi l'emploi pour les femmes
et donc on propose à lui en cours des
modes de garde diversifiés dont beaucoup
d'action l'égalité où en est on cette
question a encore il faut la poser
aujourd'hui ce chiffre qui revient
souvent sur les les salaires les hommes
touchent en moyenne 18,6 pour cent de
fois de plus ce pardon que les femmes on
est encore loin de cette égalité moi la
question s'adresse à vous deux cathy
blondeau peut-être alors nous
effectivement dans l'exposition sera
ayant affiché on a voulu mettre les
chiffres qui sont à ses émissions en
valeur donc 18,6 pour cent de
différences de salaires mais également
tout autre type de différenciation n'est
par exemple sur 0 femmes dans les
personnalités préférées des français
on a vraiment des chiffres qui sont
assez éloquents mais je pense qu'il ya
vraiment tout un historique par rapport
à ça en fait cette année les 75 ans des
droits de vote pour les femmes et je
trouve ça intéressant de voir tout ce
qui a déjà pu être fait et tout ce qui
reste à faire
non sur l'exposition soyons d'afficher
16 artistes ou collectifs se sont joints
à vous il ya des affiches des dessins
vidéos également des infographies avec
des des chiffres qui sont mises en est
mise en exergue ces différents formats
ça permet de rendre l'exposition ludique
de parler de cette thématique de
l'égalité femmes hommes de manière
ludique
on a voulu rassembler des femmes et des
hommes artiste qui chacun travaille
autour de cette thématique de l'égalité
d'avoir différents médiums donc
effectivement
des affiches de la vidéo pour que chacun
puisse se retrouver dans ces chiffres
c'est à dire que ça puisse parler du
plus petit au plus âgé
donc on peut approfondir bien évidemment
à travers cette exposition cette
thématique d'avoir des artistes très
engagé d'avoir vraiment une vision
vallières esthétique sociale mais aussi
politique de cette thématique est quand
même thématique assez forte
il ya des chiffres édifiants notamment
qu'on découvre dans cette exposition
celui ci que je ne connaissais pas
seulement 2% des rues en france portent
le nom d'une femme dire que malgré les
nombreux combats menés par des femmes
les femmes aussi qui ont fait l'histoire
de ce pays
les choses évoluent peu marie-christine
le tarn a dit c'est pour ça aussi qu'on
a pris cette thématique l'égalité on en
étant puisque pendant plus d'un mois
ça va nous permettre de réfléchir et
d'avoir des échanges collectifs sur ce
sujet alors il ya beaucoup d'avancées
qui ont été faites depuis de nombreuses
années tous nos toiles ça a été bien
parce que ça a permis de libérer la
parole des femmes ça c'est effectivement
une bonne chose
dommage d'en être arrivé là mais voilà
ça a libéré la parole des femmes mais il
y a des acquis qui sont là mais il va
falloir continuer à lutter pour que ces
acquis effectivement reste et que les
avancées on continue chaque jour à avoir
un petit peu plus de résultats et c'est
un combat de tous les jours c'est un
combat de tous les jours et vous parliez
tout à l'heure des noms des rues et nous
avec lui en cours on essaye
effectivement d'ancrer dans la mémoire
de la ville
des noms comme bat caroline est de
l'islande en olympe de gouges enfin
voilà on essaye à chaque fois de dossi
de proposer des noms de femmes
on va avoir deux lieux emblématiques à
guyancourt qui vont s'ouvrir d'ici
d'ici quelques semaines c'est le ram
donc ça sera le nom de madeleine brès
c'est la première pédiatre femmes
pédiatre et puis joséphine baker pour un
autre lieu d'accueil parents donc voila
quand on peut on continue effectivement
à donner des noms des femmes parce que
ça c'est important pour garder dans la
mémoire pour la dernière minute de cet
entretien donc il ya cette exposition
soyons affiché quel sera le programme
qu'elle teasing vous pouvez faire sur ce
temps des femmes qui va se dérouler pour
le plus gros du programme au mois de
mars cet accord sur le temps des femmes
on a donc l'ouverture du temps des
femmes qui se fait avec cette exposition
soit ayant affiché et après le temps des
femmes est en fait un nom
dédiés à tous femmes et hommes ponctuée
de différentes rencontres on peut avoir
des conférences on peut avoir des
spectacles on a des concerts on a
vraiment tout type de programmation pour
pouvoir séduire tout type de public et
on peut retrouver la programmation assez
rapidement qui va arriver là d'ici une
quinzaine de jours
mais la volonté on n'aura pas le temps
d'en parler mais d'associer aussi les
enfants à ce temps des femmes 300
enfants qui seront associés oui c'est
entre autres sur cette exposition où il
ya ça c'est important puisque la
jeunesse il faut effectivement qu'on
déjà dès maintenant dès le départ
pouvoir travailler donc avec leurs
enseignants ils vont aussi réfléchir sur
la thématique sur l'égalité
effectivement ferment toutes les
informations sur le temps des femmes à
retrouver sur le site de guyancourt
merci marie christine mètres des quais
et cathy blandeau d'avoir été avec nous
et puis pour refermer ce journal un
jeudi sur deux nous vous emmenons
désormais à la découverte d'un lieu qui
fait le patrimoine yvelinois direction
ce soir à bois d'arcy au sein du centre
national du cinéma cet ancien fort
militaire abrite les archives françaises
du film le cnc nous a exceptionnellement
ouvert ses portes
visite avec or il est onze alors on est
dans la caponnière donc était le point
stratégique de la défense de la batterie
construit à la fin du 19e siècle le fort
de bois d'arcy était destinée à
renforcer le maillot ouest des
fortifications de paris il fut un
établissement militaire jusqu'en 1945
puis gérer ensuite par le ministère de
la culture
investi par le cnc le centre national du
cinéma et de l'image animée
il accueille officiellement depuis juin
1969 les archives françaises du film 5
hectares sont entièrement dédiées à la
conservation la restauration et la
valorisation du patrimoine
cinématographique français nous
conservons donc les films sur support de
sécurité c'est-à-dire fabriqués après
1953 et des bâtiments qui sont
contrôlées en termes de température et
d'hygrométrie pour assurer la pérennité
de la pellicule trois grands silos garde
précieusement une température d'un peu
plus de 12 degrés les supports plus
contemporains pour les supports plus
anciens sur nitrate de cellulose
étant donné leur caractère inflammable
ils sont répartis dans 236 cellule en
tout un peu plus d'un millions de
bobines de films sont conservés sur le
site de bois d'arcy
c'est le bilan fait n'appartiennent pas
au cnc mais elles appartiennent à des
déposants qui nous ont confié ces
collections et que nous conservons pour
eux donc vain toutes ces personnes qui
ont déposé ces boîtes sont tout à fait
libres bien évidemment de les faire
sortir temporairement pour des
projections pour des travaux en
laboratoire ou même définitivement s'il
le souhaite également
80 personnes travaillent ici incité de
travail qui n'a pas vocation à
accueillir le public en raison des
produits chimiques hautement
inflammables qu'il renferme
lorsqu'elle arrive au cnc la pellicule
n'est pas forcément en bon état et doit
passer par la case laboratoire elle est
ensuite scannées et numérisées
donc là c'est un film en noir et blanc
une fois arrivé à retrouver les niveaux
le bon équilibre entre les noirs et
demain une restauration qui peut prendre
quelques semaines pour un film de 10
minutes et jusqu'à plusieurs mois pour
certains films neuf mois ont par exemple
été nécessaires pour le film les
misérables d'henri fait secours de 1925
sa durée de 6 heures et tout aussi
exceptionnelle nous nous attachons à
chacun de ces fibres que ce soient des
films réalisés par de grands
réalisateurs ou des films anonyme soit
conservé si vous voulez avec les mêmes
précautions pour permettre en fait de
transmettre l'ensemble de ce patrimoine
cinématographique aux générations
futures un présent inestimable bien
garder au sein de ce fort knox du
septième art
c'est la fin de ce journal les idées de
sorties dans un instant dans l'émission
le ctu loisirs de marylène iapichino
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]